[Music]
welcome everyone to the Thursday evening
lecture and this time I show you a game
that I played last year in a protest
league I played for the team from st.
Louis st. Louis Archbishop's and in this
game I'm playing in strong International
Master from Norway so d4 Knight f6 c4 g6
since we've been looking at some Kings
Indians today so I figured I continue
with that opening so you see how to play
against the Kings Indian Knight f3 d6
Bishop g5 again the name of this
variation is okay yeah well I've been
playing it true I've been playing it for
a very long time past about 25 years a
lot of a lot of games played I still
play so I used to play it when I was a
kid and I still played enjoy playing
these positions feel very comfortable
so I played hundreds of games I don't
know how many but hundreds of games
played and that's how you learn one
opening well you know otherwise you just
you're not gonna know the ideas deeply
if you keep switching from one opening
to another so to really master one
opening you have to play for a very long
time you will lose some games you'll win
some games but that will help you to
know and understand the ideas so my
opponent castled III that's the point of
this mr. petrochine
variation to put upon on a tree to try
to restrict the Bishop on G sell
normally King's Indian players they're
looking for some sharp sharp games you
know they don't want to play slow
positional so that here is you want to
kind of slow down and don't let the
Kings in their players to get their
positions so h6 played again chasing the
bishop
very very common idea see it all the
time now see five by my opponent bhai
lost his last name is Mihai la
sebastiana mihail of d5e six so now we
are actually gonna switch to another
opening in just couple of more moves and
that opening is going to be Ben Oni you
will see the structure is going to
remind you of Ben Oni right it's like
this you could get this position if you
place the Ben Oni why did I play the
move Knight d2 here who can tell me the
idea behind this move and they're
actually a few ideas behind it and why
did I play it Caleb
correct
92 ideas absolutely correct that takes
takes Bishop g4 is out there might be an
idea there is something else something
else he can try to do but after 92 I'm
not letting him do that with what is the
very common idea that black usually
plays here after he plays h6 after he
plays h6 he normally plays g5 right
sorry and now if you dropped here
tonight I try it's not possible because
you got your queen there okay
so that's why I played the move 92
multi-purpose move and I knew kind of
he's gonna take on d5 so then I can take
back with my pawn and now I have the
knight c4 idea excellent outpost for my
knight to go to see for ya Knight d7
it's important to catch up on your
development if you feel like you're
behind see it's it's easy to play the
move Knight c4 and forget about
development but then he plays Knight b6
and you don't accomplish that much
and plus you're behind in development
you don't want to be behind in
development too much okay Bishop e2 I
play catching up on that development and
it's always a good idea to be one move
away from cancelling okay you don't want
to be in complicated position where you
need two moves to castle this is very
important to know you want to be like
one move away from castling if danger
happens you castle if you're two tree
moves away that could be a problem so
try to see if you're behind in
development make moves so you know one
move away from canceling because at the
end of the day safety of your King is
your number one priority before you do
anything else
so safety important okay don't keep the
King in the middle too long a sixth oh
this is very concrete now whenever they
play a six in this kind of structures
and this is a Ben Oni structure what is
the move that you play without thinking
basically because you need this move
kneel a four you cannot allow him to
play b5 okay you cannot allow him to do
that okay
so that's why you play this move
now he goes Queenie seven
now what do we do
castle g5 you should be 395 my opponent
is trying to activate his pieces and
that way he stops me from playing 94 so
what do you think I should do now well a
four damn you cannot just a 494 are you
sure about this you have to be you have
to be careful then okay that's what I
played very good move by Caleb yes it's
called restricting controlling the
square on g4
so the Nike never go there that gives my
King an escape square here as well the
King can go too
and now I'm preparing to play f4 now he
goes back ninety eight he wants to start
pushing his pawn so what should we do
now
he's it time to play it
do you think is a time to play a four or
a little bit more preparation needed
absolutely
developing the queen connecting the
rooks right the rooks are now connected
on the background and now if you need it
you can quickly swing the rook on it one
before you player for timing timing is
very important now he plays f4 f5 what
is he trying to do now
f4 are we gonna let him do that because
if we let him do that then he's gonna
attack our Bishop his Bishop is gonna
open up attack us so he might get some
initiative so we play the move
f4 we meet him okay now our pieces are
placed very well so we play a four we
meet him and now we get the rook only
one next now he goes nine g6 and what
was the purpose of the night on the coup
that we played a long time ago to go to
c4 and now looks at you see my moves are
very easy now it takes
take back with the pawn right now I want
to play route 81
I want to bring my rotator to it again
so he gives me a check now I have two
options I can try to go back to h2 or I
can go back to h1 so so I have two
options king h2 King h1 what do you
think yes would but you know I kind of
want to be able to tuck it in the bishop
on h2 if needed so that's why I choose
h1 it's possible to play h2 - now he
goes King h8 now which piece we want to
bring into the game here absolutely
whenever you see a position like this
and you have a rook sitting in a corner
right that rook is not doing anything so
that broken according not doing anything
so what you want to do you want to bring
the rook into the game and that's why
you play here now he goes Queen g7
96 I could do that he's gonna go look p8
though I will have this move so I wanted
to improve my bishop here so by playing
Bishop III I am now putting pressure on
this pawn and now threatening already
Knight b6 and after I captured the
Bishop then I think I will win the f5
pawn for free so that's why I played
here first rook b8 so he he sees that so
he stops that
absolutely
absolutely that is the important Bishop
and I want to get that bishop because if
I get that bishop then I'm likely to get
that f5 pawn he goes back 95 he realizes
positionally his his position is falling
apart positionally too many weaknesses
light squares are weak you know very
very difficult position for him so he
realizes you know what let me try to
throw this move in just complicate the
matters this was a quick game a
15-minute game so that's what he's
trying to do now
my queen now sorry my bishop is under
attack
he didn't blunder the night he is
attacking my bishop yeah I mean I didn't
think so
further down because I mean I mean this
movie just looks kind of nice but it's
not gonna work for him but yeah like I
say King h2 was also a very decent
alternative to King h1 okay okay but it
is what it is now we have this position
here what do we do now I captured the
night he tooks it to he took on g3 now
what do you do I do now well I don't
know Bishop e5 and your dark squares are
bit bit vulnerable
ninety-two possible but he takes Queenie
five maybe not is six first it's such a
strong pawn on e6 because it completely
shuts down this Bishop and now a five
point is hanging I know Bishop e5 is
dead it's the idea but so if there
should be five threatening checkmate on
h2 sacrifice the exchange huh
absolutely we have a such a dominating
position that we don't have to worry
about sacrificing this because now we
eliminate all the threats all the mating
threats that he had so he takes to the
Queen okay if takes back with a pawn he
drops their fire pond and then I have
two connected passed pawns so he takes
here
now
yes yeah because because otherwise I
don't know what to do with this move
here I was looking at that but then you
want drops yeah that's the problem yeah
yeah now
not quite Queen d2 first eyeing I need
six pound weaknesses around the King we
eyeing for this weaknesses now I was
King ji-sun trying to defend now that
Queen is pretty centralized so what do
we do get rid of him attack it he goes
Queen g3 attack it
now
he's threatened to trade Queens I don't
want to trade Queens queen f2 now
setting up a powerful rook g3 idea now
he goes f4 you know we to stop against
that threat and now
93
well 94 25 I mean I don't wanna give up
my d5 pawn and then his Bishop is gonna
come in into the game a 5 fixing the
queenside
so he doesn't have any kind of b5 ideas
ok
a five very strong move fixing that side
of the board now he cannot move anything
imagine down exchange for white but
complete domination black pieces are
just paralyzed they cannot move anywhere
Bishop cannot move rook cannot move
knight cannot move nothing can really
move here well it was really really
strong fixer he not he goes King h8 what
else he can do he's trying to tuck in
the King in now that Queen is a little
bit active what should we do with the
Queen
it's always attacking d5 right what is
the idea that we can do against that
Queen well Rock g3 has Queen g3 h4
attacking the Queen where is the Queen
gone now he is busy to defend this guy
he goes queen h5 the problem if he goes
now here now we are free to move the
Knight to e4 and collect collected d6
pawn okay and win the game yes
possible but I don't want to complicate
it down much
it's a possibility obviously yes why he
was queen h5 - he wants to stay on this
pawn in a sort of but now what do I do
simple and effective let's capture the
pawn I just captured played sample if it
takes Queen takes off for now it goes
there f8 get rid of the last defender
okay get rid of the last defender that's
what I would like to do now he goes here
each seven I think he might get his
Bishop out I don't want that what's
hanging what's very important her plan
of course the pond and we take that pawn
look at that position still blocks
development is incomplete here and he
just simply resigned at this point
because it's hard to find a move that is
not gonna result into a mate you know if
you move your queen somewhere you're
gonna get made it you move your knight
you don't have any good squares to meet
I mean you can do this but that runs
into a very unpleasant check check this
is another Bank for you another sucks
bank any move white black makes will
worsen his position
Sebastian Mihaylov this was a knockout
with this win this was actually the
finals yeah we we became approaches
League champions last last last year
really look at the position I mean you
know my favorite move of this game is
this move here a five not the tactics
not the other stuff not the rooks
sacrifice only five a five fixing and
stopping any country play that he wanted
it to create would be five there are
probably other ways I can try to win
maybe quicker but this way it's just
without allowing opponent to get any
counter play and that's how you want to
play in your games as well completely
shut down the counter play
okay
so h4 was important and the final
position again and once you look at it
it's just any moves he's gonna make it
worse
yes yeah he played it let's go back
we're gonna review the opening let's
review the opening then we'll discuss it
right away here so d69 f6 c4 so this is
the King's Indian so you played here
yeah you can also Castle here and then
play this six but this is okay so right
now we have a King's Indian spice no
variation right but interest you have
one opening and then couple of moves
later that opening turns into another
opening so now we have the sorry we have
the
we have the been on a structure like
this structure do you see when he has
four we have three and you have four
hundred this is a Benoni structure okay
this is the Benoni structure so that's
why couple of moves in a six is played
very important is the move a for
stopping the b5 break okay
and now again h3 controlling see then
you're trying to play a four right away
don't do that don't do that okay control
first okay here yes enough but it's yeah
it weakens the position furthermore then
actually does much by the way I can also
take here and they win upon if I really
want okay okay now we're gonna do some
really hard positions okay the
difficulty level hard okay much more
difficult alright so let's see those
positions good work everybody
good so once again important to be ready
to give up pieces sometimes here when he
was trying to checkmate thing I didn't
start run away you know I just sacrifice
because I had so much you know such a
strong position that I could even play
around down exchange so that's why put
your pieces on good squares control the
center that pawn on e6 I had was giving
me so much compensation that I could I
could afford to sacrifice the exchange
and play like that white to play and win
this is 2016 us championship game
yeah but okay you need to calculate yeah
let have a follow-up Brooke the six
takes sorry rook c8 rook e8 so dr. sex
take rook e8
takes yeah you gotta be careful yeah
you cannot just give up all the pieces
[Laughter]
but instead he just just won the game in
four moves in four moves he defeated a
strong opponent Grandmaster oh nice
choke nil
Luke II five by nil
okay so let's try to understand what's
going on here
Bishop takes background made rook takes
takes yeah now if he takes again
checkmate and if you go I think this is
the game he won here and now rock this
when he goes here and threating
background made he goes you're okay sir
okay all right in Group B savages wins
and if he plays f5 who is gonna find a
winning tactic now Caleb take take take
take okay see you have to always look
for this kind of ideas and again why
black is having this problem because
which movie forgot to play or he didn't
manage to do it in time lift he forgot
to create his flight square for the King
Duluth okay and that's why it's a
trouble okay the flight square or the
lift he forgot to create this is the
game Wesley so Hikaru Nakamura played
here in st. Louis okay two years ago why
to play and win
how did Wesley son managed to defeat
Nakamura
okay Queen h5
Bishop d1 attacking the Queen if it
takes rook takes right
she goes to h6 you take here Bishop
takes so take
take the queen actually he has a little
bit of a compensation here maybe because
he's got a bishop rook and a pawn a
little bit of a compass
excellent Caleb yes not rushing it Queen
is still there
Queen is not going anywhere so you take
back with the Queen and now the queen or
h5 is trapped yeah if it takes yeah the
queen is simply trapped so that's why
you have to be careful I think it was
one of those variations where black took
on h4 you know they took upon Bishop
takes Knight takes Queen takes and and
then it turned out to be poisoned pawn
you know later on because so probably
the last one was a blunder by black
allowing this but again Bishop comes
here always look when you playing always
look for Tempest always look for moose
that give you this tempos ideas okay all
right thanks thank you everybody for
attending the lecture and we'll see you
this next week okay
[Music]